I think Apple could come out with a
sneaker that would do well thanks on its
heat but the apples losing it a little
bit but like four years ago
six years ago eight years ago Apple
could have came out with a sneaker and
[ __ ] want they were cool so they can
enter and then they innovated which is
their DNA and then you would have said
oh my god what are they gonna come out
with next yeah I don't think people are
thinking enough I'm like who could enter
right use this example nobody was
thinking about Sony as a video game
competitor to Sega and Nintendo until
they were nobody nobody was talking
about Microsoft as a video game
competitor to Nintendo and Sega until
they were you know same reason I think
BMW should be making the biggest and
best headphones in the world
I mean if fewer today BMW came out with
an $800 headphones and they work better
than Bose and better than you know Biebs
and they had that incredibly iconic logo
on the circle on the outside I'm a funny
feeling people would believe they're in
their engineering capabilities that
brand has permission to make the best
headphones in the world
[Music]
like yeah you're watching me do it in
real time I'm building brands which will
give me permission to do anything that
feels authentic and I'm capable of
executing against I'm in the business of
what can be done versus what used to be
done 99% are like no BMW makes cars I'm
in the business of VM dough you can make
headphones PBS and New York Times could
become the next generation of great
agencies I'm building one of the most
successful current agencies in the world
I ran a liquor store before I entered
I've already done it how about this I'm
talking in hypothesis and I'm actually
the living example of it I think I think
we should write an article called why
not here are the brands that have
permission and maybe we should do like
15 like prediction not predictions like
what-ifs
what if BMW competed with Beats right
why can't Nike compete with Gatorade
when I say to you if Nike came out with
a sports drink tomorrow that was
delicious
like if I say to you that happens do you
say to yourself yeah that actually
cannot like oh yeah I can see that it's
one big game of yeah you see that
it's brands brands brands that have
established something enough to have
permission to do something that makes
sense within that scene target demo just
executed in a different product or
service well I think Apple should make
televisions that's just and that's very
that's literal but like I think Apple
could come out with a sneaker that would
do well they something the apples losing
it a little bit but like four years ago
six years ago eight years ago Apple
could have came out with a sneaker and
[ __ ] one in my opinion based on it's
cool to sixteen year olds and because
they because they're what they would
have done they were cool so they can
enter and then they innovated which is
their DNA and then you would have said
oh my god what are they gonna come out
with next
[Music]
can you send a thing to the group text I
want to start out what if Wednesdays I
want to make a post for 7:30 I want
somebody on the design team to design a
product that doesn't exist in my world
that I haven't thought of yet let's uh
oh I got it
I want to call it what if Wednesday's
I'll write the copy but I wanted to I
want somebody to create a logo real fast
called what if Wednesday's and I want
the product the first product to be
Bobby baboons beef jerky there was a
vlog where I made a jokes if Tyler
babban should make a beef jerky and we
were gonna call it Bobby because that's
his real name
Bobby babban beef jerky actually you
know what we should sort of brand right
now right now
Bobby bobbins I'm involved hey guys
I want somebody to design the package
for Bobby bobbins beef jerky I'll write
the copy but every Wednesday going
forward I'm gonna make a what if
Wednesday and we're gonna make up a
product every week that we're not making
we're gonna post it and we're gonna use
that as our D and something's gonna
explode and then we're gonna actually
make it
[Music]
I mean this is look you're seeing the
2019 version of it but like literally
bro this is the conversations I had with
friends when I said let's start emailing
people instead of sending direct now
let's let's like let's I'm gonna start a
show on this new thing called YouTube
what does that even you can't imagine
how poor and that was to a world that
had no videos on the internet I'm in the
business I'm an abyss I'm in the
business of what if and yes and why not
and you know where is it going and
tomorrow and 99% of the market is in
yesterday their entire framework the
decision making is predicated on
yesterday
right
what's about to happen in America with
cloud kitchens which is a startup being
built right now by Travis Cal connect
the CEO and founder of Bluebird in the
next 18 months 40 of the major cities in
America are going to get delivered
anything they want within five to seven
minutes for free
I couldn't short 7-eleven more in the
next decade I mean it I mean it unless
they are able to execute that capability
Chicago residents in 18 months will have
an app that lets them get toothpastes or
Oreo cookies or a mountain Dew and five
to seven minutes for free
they've built contemporary kitchens and
C stores underground in warehouses in
parking garages it is unbelievable how
much disruption is coming the only thing
that's going to be left is the brand the
affinity that the consumer has for the
brand and that's it just like in
entertainment if you're following along
of what's going on with Disney and ESPN
all these things we went through 80
years where the pipes had the advantage
now the pipes are dumb and the IP has
the advantage our only move in that
environment is to create such affinity
and brand with the actual end consumer
that when mom says hey Alexa send me
some cookies she's saying hey Alexa send
me some chips to Hawaii the toll booth
that voice-activated AI devices are
gonna have in buying product seven years
from today is gonna scare this
collective movement in a way that they
can't even imagine because humans don't
care about privacy they care about
convenience and the convenience is
coming at a scale that we've never seen
the only thing left will be brand and so
I couldn't be more passionate as you can
imagine in making brand the forefront
but if you're yelling at people where
they can't hear you you're creating
nothing and so that is my passion that
is my framework that's how I see it and
for me that is only about the consumer
not about any other variable because
that is the only thing that ever matters
thank you
[Applause]
you know what's funnier and I know I
don't that's not what I do well I don't
it's not that I forecast I observe the
current and create capabilities so for
me one thing that is current enough that
is maybe it feels a little more in a
future was why I talked about voice I
think audio is exploding it's why
podcast consumptions up
it's the voice devices it's the passive
nature of the consumption of audio that
doesn't restrict you from multitasking
that gives it a very nice next decade
audio but back to being a grieving
company just for two seconds if you're
looking to acquire new clients to work
with I highly recommend you become burst
in what's going on on LinkedIn recently
it's very powerful
ya know keep doing it and it's thought
leadership the whole knife the feet it's
there it is unbelievable and it will be
lead Jed take care of Jake yes and yes
[Music]
messages yes my job is uncovering I
understand right relevant we there there
I think both matter okay tremendously
where I think we're advancing the
conversation is creating output for the
purpose of uncovering insights so much
of the content I put out in the world as
a human to your son yeah and what I do
for brands is actually to then get the
feedback to do smarter work we lived in
a world where strategy work and then you
had a singular kind of insight yeah and
then you had a insert interpretation by
a creative and you kind of like through
this big brick on the world my point of
view is a bunch of little stones oh wait
a minute they're resonating to this the
reason I can get to so much truth and
I'm getting goosebumps is because I'm
putting so much out there and then I'm
qualitatively reading what the reality -
right
and you are reacting to their it like
your it's a it's an infinite loop it's
an infinite loop
I actually don't love it coming across
motivational yeah it's that I realized
as I was talking about tactics the
biggest reason people don't do what what
they want to do is insecurity which then
led me to why are they insecure which
then led into parenting you know and so
all of a sudden I'd be coming as a
personality and output of my thesis
which is I started with tactics couldn't
understand why people logically
understood that I was right about what
they needed to do but they weren't
willing to do it and then built insights
to what led me to more macro correct
which is their mom made them feel
insecure I mean it gets tensed that's
why they're not posting other people's
opinions right my my passion and why
started vaynermedia is to actually buy a
nostalgic France which is why I haven't
started what otherwise I would have to
buy them and refurbish them so my big
thing is I want its most basic form I
want to build the reverse of private
equity in a private equity machine
meaning when I buy a brand tootsie rolls
or you know mug root beer at Pepsi I
want that's a good one when I buy mug
like everybody buys brands from big food
companies as PE burns
you know orphan brands and they cut
costs and they create operational
efficiencies and then they flip it I
wanted I want to I want a triple revenue
in 48 months that's the machine that's
the hit point oh sure
love you guys take care bye bye about
thank you
[Music]